For our second present, for the Second Day of Christmas,
we have two blankets.
They are similar in some ways.
I got one in July and the other one in December.
So let's have a look at the first one.
It's quite big and you can see I am not good at making beds.
You can see, it's a present from the American Chemical Society.
I gave a lecture in July to the Annual General Meeting of the Royal Society of Chemistry.
They thought I'd make it a bit more exciting.
The president of the American Chemical Society was there,
and a few weeks later, this came through the post...
...with a note saying that the president had loved my lecture and here was a present.
It really is a blanket, and it's pretty up to date.
(It's) got flerovium and livermorium.
You can wear it, if you want, like a cloak
Brady: Oh yeah, like a chemical Jedi.
Prof: That's the first one, let's lay it on the bench.
The second one is quite similar.
It is also a blanket,
but, it's actually what, in American, is called a quilt,
and in England is called an eiderdown.
This is what you put on the top of your bed.
My arms aren't quite long enough.
And, this had been stitched by a special stitching machine.
It looks as if it's hand made, but in fact, it's quite a cunning piece of computer programming.
This was given to me by Theo Grey, who is famous for his periodic tables.
He has a machine. I'm not quite sure what it's for,
but one of the things it can do is to produce these quilts.
I had huge problems bringing this back on the train from London, where I was given it.
Eventually, I wrapped it up in a plastic sheet with a luggage strap 'round it.
And I met a fan on the train, but I didn't have the courage to unwrap it.
I think that these are both really nice.
I haven't got the slightest idea what to do with them,
because I don't really want to have them on my bed.
Well, I would like to, but I'm not sure other members of my family would be quite so keen.
But, I think in the end we'll hang them up here in the School of Chemistry at Nottingham.
On the Second Day of Christmas, we have two periodic table blankets,
on the First Day of Christmas, we had some tartaric acid from a wine barrel.
Now, let's see what we're going to have on day three.